[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález chile va a
las urnas el próximo domingo en unas
elecciones presidenciales históricas por
la coyuntura en la que tienen el lugar
una convención constitucional que está
avanzando y de la que saldrá una nueva
carta magna para este país también un
malestar en la ciudadanía que llevó al
estallido social y al estado de
excepción un presidente que acaba de
sortear un segundo intento de juicio
político también una recuperación
económica post confinamiento y tras el
cierre de las fronteras debido a la
pandemia del 19 y también una alta y
bueno así visto desde afuera como
exitosa vacunación a nivel internacional
también una serie de candidatos 7 en
total que no superan los márgenes
necesarios para tener la intención de
voto por lo que será necesario ir a una
segunda vuelta es lo más seguro lo que
dicen
encuestas estos son los candidatos que
están aspirando para llegar al palacio
de la moneda veamos algunos de ellos o
veamos los a ellos al completo mejor
gabriel boric es de la coalición apruebo
dignidad jose antonio kast del partido
republicano sebastián sitges de vamos
chile también está yasna provoste del
nuevo pacto social franco parisi de el
partido de la gente marco enríquez
ominami del partido progresista y
eduardo artés de la unión patriótica dos
de ellos pasarán a esta segunda vuelta
presidencial en chile
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
gonzalo müller ls director del centro de
políticas públicas de la red está en la
ciudad de santiago la capital chilena
también está con nosotros a darío
quiroga analista político experto en
sociología y ciencias políticas y
también asesor de comunicaciones él
también se encuentra en la ciudad de
santiago en la capital chilena y aquí en
el estudio de france 24 está con
nosotros josé manuel rivas en los
profesores de ciencia política de la
universidad san buenaventura de la
ciudad de bogotá en colombia ustedes
nuestros televidentes también pueden
participar en este debate dejen todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas lo
pueden hacer a través de las redes
sociales no se encuentran en facebook en
instagram también en twitter estamos
como arroba france24
s lees en recuerdo cuál es la etiqueta
es numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos
todos sus comentarios y preguntas
relacionadas con este tema comienza
entonces a preguntarle a nuestro
invitado a gonzalo me oler en santiago
en la capital de chile que tanto está en
juego en estas elecciones
de alguna manera muchos las han
calificados como unas elecciones
inciertas y muy abiertas porque rompe
con esas dos caras de la moneda a la que
estaban habituados los chilenos a la
hora de votar
así así yo creo que la incertidumbre es
una palabra importante para describir
esta elección no sólo por el resultado
sino por el cambio que van a significar
ahora
y apareciera su nómina la encuesta la
expectativa está puesta en que los dos
grandes bloques no pasen la segunda
buena es que necesitan todo lo que el
argumento fue la concertación a la nueva
mayoría a través de hoy día representa
la cantidad de yasna provoste no llegue
a la segunda vuelta lo mismo el
candidato del oficialismo o sea éste
asistió también por primera vez no
pasarían a la segunda vuelta marcando un
cambio de un eje que se ha venido
construyendo la sociedad chilena de lo
nuevo del sur lo viejo en este caso son
las dos alternativas pistas como nuevas
son las de aquellas que estarían
liderando en el caso de gabriel boric y
josé antonio kast pero no solamente está
ese eje operando también hay un eje que
tiene que ver con el estallido social
vivió el 2019 donde ha producido un
cambio importante la política chilena no
olvidemos el de chile inicio para
propósitos de ese pedido social un
acuerdo o un acuerdo nacional por una
reforma una nueva avanzar hacia una
nueva constitución que terminó en un
plebiscito constitucional en el año
y 2020 en octubre el 2020 y finalmente
en la elección de convencionales en mayo
de este año y esa es una convención
constitucional que está trabajando ahora
el gobierno que se ha visto sin control
a través de como lo describe bueno de
escribíamos a través de las acusaciones
constitucional y todo paralizado y ajeno
además de no tener un representante
claro y nítido en la propia elección
presidencial eso quizá ha generado la
incertidumbre ha generado grandes
movimientos entre los distintos
candidatos y que los favoritos muchas
veces de la encuesta no pudieran
terminar ratificándolo finalmente las
elecciones como ocurrió en la primaria
darío también allí en la capital de
chile en la ciudad de santiago su
opinión qué es lo que está en juego en
estas elecciones como ya lo decíamos
abiertas distintas atípicas para los
chilenos son unas elecciones poco
convencionales
si son unas elecciones poco
convencionales hay una gran pregunta de
hecho hay preguntas muy contradictorias
yo creo que
alguien podría pensar que son las
elecciones más importantes los últimos
años porque nos guste el ciclo desde el
18 octubre de 2019 desde el estadio
social chileno obviamente que ha hecho
que todo cambie radicalmente es solo en
estos últimos dos años se fue por el
caño la constitución del 80 de pinochet
de la dictadura prácticamente se ha
terminado con el sistema
económico de las afp las de los fondos
de pensiones ha habido cambio sustantivo
entonces lo podría pensar todas las
elecciones tremendamente importantes
pero por otra parte hay una cierta
dicotomía con esta energía social que
uno puede percibir en la sociedad valga
la redundancia pero que en esta cosa
extraña de candidaturas que emergen que
suben y que después bajan rápidamente
pareciera ser que el poder cada vez está
menos en los espacios de representación
formal incluso en la presidencia de
república y a veces uno podría poner en
duda si realmente es una elección muy
importante o muy por el contrario es una
elección poco importante porque sea
quien sea
los favoritos que termine imponiéndose
en el balotaje del 19 de diciembre es
bien probable que la capacidad de que
por lo tanto la la sociedad en su
conjunto tome una decisión de apoyar de
seguir cierto proyecto yo creo que está
en veremos es decir para decirlo en
términos muy simples es muy probable que
gane quien gane la elección presidencial
qué sé yo a los seis meses de gobierno
tengan niveles de popularidad bajísimo y
por lo tener por lo tanto tenga grandes
dificultades para darle gobernabilidad y
para avanzar en su proyecto político
ya que en el estudio de france 24 jose
manuel lo que veíamos de chile y lo que
estábamos habituados era un país muy
organizado un ejemplo para la región un
país con una economía pujante saliendo
adelante y lo que vemos ahora es que el
país o por lo menos los ciudadanos
quieren un cambio por completo del
modelo económico del modelo político que
tiene el país y eso también está en
cierta forma en juego porque el
presidente que llegue le va a tocar esta
nueva constitución que está siendo
redactada estamos ante la apertura de un
verdadero chile este chile que tiene
esta grande social o simplemente salió a
la región ha sido un momento otro con el
estado social o este es un país que
siempre ha tenido estas características
y
simplemente estalló de un momento a otro
mi lectura sobre la situación chilena es
que chile desde la transición a la
democracia ha vivido una especie de
situación excepcional con un corsé que
estableció la dictadura de pinochet con
la constitución de 1980 y sobre todo con
el sistema electoral con distritos
binominales que que obligó a los
partidos políticos y al sistema de
partido naturalmente en chile-
pluripartidista pluralista a
organizarse por ese sistema electoral
dos grandes coaliciones a partir de la
reforma de 2015 creo que empiezan los
cambios en chile y chile como país
empieza a desplegarse de ese corsé que
que no sólo eran términos de partidos
sino también un corsé en términos
políticos y económicos ya que en la
dictadura de pinochet fue capaz de pues
de dejar el proyecto de país cerrado en
los siguientes décadas y esto ha ido
cambiando con estas reformas que se
hicieron también a veces pero la reforma
del año 2012 de piñera con el voto que
pasó de ser obligatorio a ser voluntario
y el censo de ser voluntaria será
automático también cambio las
circunstancias no y repartió de nuevo
las varas en términos de los equilibrios
entre los partidos y lo que estamos
viendo no creo que sea un cambio tan
nuevo sino que viene realmente de la
última década es un proceso gradual que
tiene en cuenta también que tenemos que
tener en cuenta también el contexto no
sé que usted mencionaba también en la
presentación del caso
me parece que coincide también con mis
compañeros anteriores en que vivimos un
periodo de incertidumbre no precisamente
porque el país está liberando de ese
corsé que mencionaba no en términos
político incertidumbre del país está
abriendo está mostrando una cara que no
conocíamos de chile por lo menos en la
región de américa latina gonzalo para
los que estamos fuera de las fronteras
de chile que era el país ejemplo para
muchos de nosotros en la región que es
lo que prima ahora en las candidaturas
de estos siete candidatos que están
aspirando a llegar a la moneda cuáles
han sido los temas que han dominado el
debate público por supuesto está el
estallido social que es digamos que un
punto de partida para el escenario en el
que está chile en este momento pero que
otras prioridades tiene el país y están
en juego en esos planes de gobierno
yo creo que para la diferencia quizás
otras elecciones los programas o las
agendas ha sido menos relevantes que lo
que cada candidato busca identificar lo
que son de alguna manera estas
identidades políticas nuevas identidades
políticas hemos visto que incluso los
propios candidatos no le han dado la
prioridad su programa modificando los
cambiando luego muchas presionando
explicaciones por ello se entiende de
que no han sido los protagonistas sino
que han sido los propios candidatos y lo
que logran identificar dentro de este
sentimiento nacional por qué digo
sentimiento que el a partir del
plebiscito de octubre sale un
sentimiento de esperanza y cambio y se
ha ido matizando más matizando por
desórdenes por violencia por también un
período muy largo de espera para obtener
frutos no y eso creo que ha generado
también una necesidad de mayor orden y
personas que empezaron a valorar el
orden la recuperación económica
christina ha sido afectado por la
pandemia al igual que el mundo nuevo y
americana y por lo tanto de más temas de
la cotidianidad de lo laboral
de los desafíos de las necesidades de
orden y seguridad se han puesto muy por
sobre la mesa y eso ha generado quizá la
irrupción de estos dos nuevos candidatos
que visibilizan estos dos sentimientos
que le da continuidad al sentimiento que
nace en octubre del estallido social que
también por esta y por otra una reacción
de orden una reacción más de seguridad y
de cuidar lo que se tiene de los de los
avances que ha obtenido la sociedad
chilena que se ha venido identificando
en torno al candidato claro antonio kast
lo que no hay que olvidar si hay que a
pesar de que ambos candidatos lideran
las preferencias ambos lo hacen
comporten con porcentajes bastante bajos
si
gonzalo que si precisamente esta falta
de tener unos programas estructurados
que de verdad muestren soluciones a los
reclamos de la sociedad chilena está
llevando a esta apatía electoral que se
está percibiendo desde ya con una baja
intención de voto o que muchos de los
encuestados en las calles de la ciudad
chilenas no saben por quién votar
así es yo creo que hay dos dos fenómenos
que explican eso primero que creciendo
mucho el tipo de lector que ya no tiene
identificación el eje izquierda-derecha
tradicional no tiene identificación
partidaria tampoco y por lo tanto está
muy sujeto a inclinarse de acuerdo a los
temas que tienen la agenda política o en
la agenda pública por eso los debates
entre los presidenciables ha adquirido
mayor importancia que en elecciones
anteriores esa información es un tipo de
lector que en las últimas dos semanas
termina definiendo su voto y muchas
veces sorprendiendo al sistema político
en general a la lógica política
tradicional no de ordenamiento izquierda
a derecha darío teniendo claro este
panorama que nos explica gonzalo con
estos ciudadanos que todavía no han
definido por quién van a votar
básicamente los indecisos como se les
llama pues ya literalmente y la baja
participación que ha marcado el chile en
las últimas elecciones que va a ser cuál
va a ser la pieza clave entonces para
definir ese balotaje el 19 de diciembre
en ese grupo de indecisos ya están muy
marcados van a votar por cast y por y
por boris que son los que posiblemente
puedan pasar a esa segunda vuelta
yo discrepo de alguno de los fundamentos
que se plantean para garantir por el
final a mí me parece que el
resultado de la elección del balotaje
prácticamente sin duda alguna va a
inclinarse por gabriel boric porque
alguna manera es quien representa
de mejor manera sin ser un símbolo del
estallido social pero evidentemente es
de esta nueva izquierda joven que ya
emergió hace algunos años atrás que ha
copado y que alguna manera representa
esta sensación de cambio lo cual por
supuesto no implica que hacer una cosa
lineal y que sea una carrera corrida
pero quiero decir por ejemplo yo creo
que más que apatía lo que pasa que está
muy variable porque hay una expresión y
es uno incluso puede entenderlo
sistémicamente hay una energía que
libera el estallido social y que incluso
con el fenómeno de la pandemia posterior
cuesta que cuaje entre otras cosas
porque el propio sistema le cuesta como
procesar esa energía o derechamente a
veces limita esa energía deja ponerse
sólo un ejemplo para que se entienda el
mayo recién pasado se eligieron los con
los
constituyentes los delegados para
redactar la nueva constitución la que va
a reemplazar y se hizo un sistema
político un sistema electoral un sistema
de elección para elegir
155 delegados es la misma cantidad del
parlamento que utilizaron los mismos
distritos que son 28 a nivel nacional
pero se hicieron tres cambios
fundamentales que permitieron que se
inscribieran listas independientes se
hizo una elección paritaria 50% y 50% y
se hicieron escaños reservados para
pueblos originarios indígenas esos tres
cambios lograron que se generara una
representación nunca antes vista que fue
valor valorada por moro y cristiano sin
embargo seis meses después cuando
estamos ahora portas de la elección de
un nuevo parlamento los mismos 155 no se
hizo ningún cambio y se va a elegir de
la manera antigua sin paridad sin listas
independientes sin escaño reservado es
una muestra más como todavía estamos en
un proceso de corcoveó donde la clase
política muchos sectores yo diría
especialmente la derecha pero no
solamente ellos
de alguna manera intentan contener los
cambios que seguramente se van a dar por
lo tanto yo creo que más que una patilla
hay mucha variabilidad en la elección de
los candidatos importante este punto que
nos explica darío josé manuel estas
conversiones y cambios que ha hecho
chile que nos explicaba que nos
explicaba el esto de cierta forma sirve
también de ejemplo para otros países en
la región para américa latina para otros
países que también tuvieron diferentes
manifestaciones ciudadanas a lo largo
del año pasado después del estallido
social en chile caso colombia por
ejemplo
como puede servir esta experiencia que
está viviendo chile este despertar esta
apertura para otros países de la región
un chile en 2019 no pues fue el
iniciador uno de los movimientos de
protestas en américa latina' sin embargo
consideró que el el contexto de colombia
es diferente porque a diferencia de
chile colombia si tiene una constitución
que surge en un proceso constituyente no
con iniciativa popular una constitución
además que tiene un fuerte contenido
social
en cambio la constitución chilena venía
de la dictadura de pinochet y había una
creencia histórica por por cambiar la
constitución por iniciar un proceso
constituyente algo que no creo que se
traduzca en colombia los puntos que veo
en común en este sentido entre los dos
países es sobre todo un cambio en los
principales protagonistas de la
contienda política mientras que en chile
estamos viendo como las coaliciones
tradicionales ahora las encuestas las
posiciones fuera del balotaje en cambio
en colombia también en las encuestas
preelectorales que estamos viendo vemos
a candidatos que también pues son ajenos
no a los partidos tradicionales
colombianos y a las coaliciones
políticas tradicionales y que están
punteando las encuestas y en este
sentido creo que la traducción difícil
como dice el compañero anterior no
difícil pero en el sistema político de
los cambios sociales sobre todo se da a
través de los partidos y de la
transformación en el sistema de partidos
insisto con ese términos en algo la
ronda la inversa para avisarle a mis
compañeros en el máster voy entonces con
darío en la ciudad de santiago y quiero
que hablemos de los a todos los que han
sobresalido en los últimos días después
de esos debates televisivos que fueron
muy comentados allí en chile por
supuesto y hablo de josé antonio kast y
de gabriel boric
son completamente diferentes
muestran un espectro completamente
diferente a nivel político uno tiene un
digamos una larga trayectoria a nivel
política a nivel y gabriel boric no es
de santiago viene de la región viene de
magallanes es un joven es de izquierda
representa una esencia muy diferente a
nivel político a lo que están
acostumbrados los chilenos
si completamente yo creo que son dos
candidaturas que están muy en las
antípodas y que son ambos muy distintos
a lo que comúnmente estábamos
acostumbrados si bien josé antonio kast
proviene de la udi fue diputado durante
tres o cuatro pedidos muchos años
etcétera pero de alguna manera ha ido
cultivando un perfil ahí aparece en
pantalla un perfil similar digamos un
poco lo que podría ser una mezcla entre
trump evolucionar aunque al estilo
chileno es decir sin sin tantas
estridencias lo que sí son bastante
estridentes muy estridentes son partes
sus posturas que de hecho ha tenido que
ir las matizando porque recordemos que
josé antonio kast que iba por fuera de
la derecha tradicional tenía una tenía
una expectativa yo creo máximo llegar
quizás a un 15 por ciento y por lo tanto
hizo un programa que es muy duro muy
fuerte contra la inmigración de grandes
menoscabos por ejemplo proponía entre
otras cosas eliminar el ministerio de la
mujer etcétera cosa que seguramente va a
tener que retractar y suavizar y en el
caso gabriel boric en realidad lo
interesante de abrir boliches que es es
de la camada de los dirigentes
estudiantiles que emergen del 2011 hace
10 años atrás
se hicieron diputados políticos y que
hoy en día representa por supuesto con
las complejidades de un liderazgo joven
y de una coalición el frente amplio más
el partido comunista que tiene muy poca
experiencia gobernando incluso
enfrentando la campaña por lo tanto yo
creo que ha sido en realidad una de dos
alternativas de contraste y va a ser yo
creo si lo digo más allá de mis propias
preferencias y me mira un poco más
profunda lo digo que sí va a ser yo creo
bien extraño estar en algunos días más
con el 99% probabilidades enfrentado a
una segunda vuelta con dos candidatos
que son bastante digamos que tienen una
distancia ideológica unos con otros
bastante grande yo no diría extremos
porque en caso gabriel boric es una
izquierda bastante moderada con un
pasado en la calle etcétera pero que hoy
en día sus propuestas son bastante
moderadas no básicas y yo sí lo
calificaría más de ultraderecha pero la
distancia entre ambos indudablemente no
es la que estábamos acostumbrados cuando
se elegía entre candidatos de centro
centroizquierda y de una derecha
democrática más liberal
gonzalo su opinión sobre estos dos
candidatos que son como los que están
liderando encuestas y percepciones allí
en santiago no podemos decir números
previo a las elecciones pero pero cuál
es su opinión
yo creo que como veíamos representando
un mundo muy distinto
a la centroizquierda y centroderecha la
desbordado candidatos a su derecho ya su
izquierda y que buscan reemplazar las de
alguna manera esa es la tesis de ambos
reemplazar al viejo régimen ambos en eso
se parece también separación en que es
percibido por la ciudadanía como
reformista aunque el tema distinto en el
reformismo de izquierda siempre en macro
es macro no parte de la constitución y
va bajando en cambio el que ofrece un
reformismo que tiene que ver con la
cotidianidad con la vida diaria contable
más seguridad mejor trabajo a las
personas más garantías en paz de lo
cotidiano cuando nos va convergiendo yo
creo que ambos que para poder ganar de
alguna manera polarizaron su discurso y
es por eso que no es casual de que ambos
hayan relativizado sus programas no en
el caso de gabriel boric la presencia
del partido comunista en su alianza lo
polariza y genera dudas y para mucha
gente eso es lo que nos mueve hacia la
extrema izquierda no el propiamente
compañía el caso josé antonio kast
también le ocurre algo similar en su
programa también estaba escrito como un
programa para polarizar no muy radical
muy de propuestas de blanco y negro y
por tanto lo más probable es que ambos
de pasar de concretarse a una segunda
vuelta lo que vamos a ver es cómo harán
de moderar fuertemente no sólo su
programa sino también sus mensajes antes
ahora ya no la obligación de triunfar
frente a su alternativa del pasado no
tengo régimen de la centroizquierda
centroderecha
cada uno sino que ver cómo logran
consolidarse es el futuro ahora ya van a
haber dos candidatos del nuevo desde el
nuevo chile por decirlo así y las
personas van a empezar a mirar cuál va a
ser más capaz de cumplir con lo que
ofrece cuál de los dos les da más
seguridad y cuál se parece más a las
necesidades alguien eloy díaz josé
manuel aquí en el estudio de france 24
veamos el panorama de la región
así como chile tiene estas dos
diferentes tendencias en estos dos
candidatos que posiblemente sean los que
pasen a esta segunda vuelta la región
américa latina y particularmente américa
del sur también está un poco
en cierto balance con gobiernos de
izquierda y gobiernos un poco más de
derecha o de ultraderecha si nos vamos
hasta brasil y lo que fue el gobierno
trump que cambió a principio de año en
eeuu
chile en donde lo podemos encajar con
estos dos candidatos dependiendo de
quién gane como en qué parte del
rompecabezas podría entrar
bueno en américa latina' la verdad es
que en los últimos años está ocurriendo
un fenómeno vinculado sobre todo a la
matriz productiva no a partir de la
crisis de los precios del petróleo de
2014 2013-2014 hubo un deterioro de la
opinión pública hacia las instituciones
especialmente hacia los gobiernos y en
américa latina que son sistemas
presidencialistas hacia la figura
presidencial y esto inició un proceso
que ya no está tan claro en cuanto a los
giros ideológicos en los 90 todo el
mundo tenía claro que américa latina
había girado a la derecha con el
neoliberalismo en los 2000 hacia la
izquierda no con los gobiernos
progresistas más o menos radicales en
cambio a partir de esta crisis de los
precios del petróleo
un territorio en disputa en términos
políticos donde las elecciones son cada
vez más disputadas en segunda vuelta no
lo hemos visto en el caso de argentina
en dos ocasiones lo hemos visto también
en perú en colombia no lo hemos visto
todavía tan disputada la segunda vuelta
pero seguramente el año que viene esté
también bastante disputada o eso se
prevé en los sondeos y chile sigue esa
estela la diferencia es que a diferencia
de otros países chile tiene un sistema
de partidos
compartidos tradicionales poderosos y
estos nuevos partidos no son partidos
anti sistémicos en general sino son
partidos que continúan la estela de los
partidos anteriores que reformulan
propuestas en términos de izquierda y
derecha
por ejemplo cast realmente es parecido
en españa' vox es una decisión de la udi
y en el caso de bórico viene de los
movimientos sociales de abajo pero
cuando cuando llegan a instancias
institucionales si se moderan un
parecido también a lo que ocurrió en
españa con podemos me parece que el caso
de de chile en términos internos se
asemeja más a españa incluso algunos
países europeos en este sentido en cómo
se organizan los partidos que incluso a
los países latinoamericanos vecinos que
aunque tienen esa lógica polarizante los
partidos políticos tienen naturaleza
sustancialmente diferente muchas veces
anti programática también el estilo no
de hacer política mucho más podríamos
decir demagógico no mientras que en
chile cualquier candidato incluso la
extrema derecha mantiene la calma que es
lo que también mencionaba mi compañero
antes y con lo que estoy de acuerdo sí
que mantienen un poco el status quo de
lo que ha venido viviendo chile desde
que entró a la democracia quiero
preguntarle a gonzalo sobre el candidato
que llegue a la presidencia que llegue
al palacio de la moneda tendrá que ser
digamos una especie el gobierno de
transición como lo ven ustedes porque la
carta magna- nueva que entre en
funciones allí en chile
lo hará dentro de esta nueva
administración puede ser un periodo
presidencial de pronto más corto puede
que sea un período presidencial
completo y que sea el encargado de hacer
muchas más modificaciones más allá de
ese plan de gobierno que está planteando
que piensa usted
bueno primero yo creo que si parte de la
incertidumbre tiene que ver eso
finalmente el proceso constituyente
terminado cruzado por la elección
presidencial y parlamentaria es decir el
proceso constituyente que lleva a
avanzar en su parte más sustantiva no va
a aprobar normas en enero del próximo
año va a enfrentar de que en marzo todo
va a haber un nuevo presidente y un
nuevo congreso y probablemente con un
alineamiento político diverso o igual si
es igual en situar una sincronía no va a
haber un alineamiento entre la
suspensión por ejemplo gabriel boric y
un congreso también con un gran
presencia de la izquierda eso lo podría
simplificar pero también puede ocurrir
no es descartable no aparte de la
incertidumbre es que cale josé antonio
kast él viene ganando la presidencia y
que desalineado él es un gran crítico
del trabajo de la constitucional y por
lo tanto va a usar ese argumento en la
versión es que yo con mayoría absoluta
también como un elemento de presión
sobre el trabajo de la propia convención
constitucional para hacer choque de
legitimidades y lo ven de alguna manera
un choque de poderes
hay un fenómeno que yo creo que se va a
mantener en la política chilena es que
él ya los últimos dos mandatos pero
sobre todo éste se ha producido un
fenómeno que es el presidencialismo en
nuestro sistema pero de minorías
parlamentarias y por lo tanto se produce
hay un bloqueo entre la mayoría de
opositora en el congreso y esa mayoría
en el ejecutivo distinto distintos
signos eso no logró ser resuelto de
alguna manera en este periodo y quizás
en el próximo albert vamos a ver vamos a
tener un congreso aún más fragmentado
donde ninguno de los candidatos
presidenciales más potentes va a tener
una mayoría por sí misma sino que en
alianza con otros y hay un último factor
que no lo convenció nada yo creo que
también lo puedo dejar fuera porque es
parte de lo que está ocurriendo en la
sociedad y en el sistema político
chileno hay una gran desconfianza hacia
la política una gran crítica hacia la
política y eso ha provocado que hay un
candidato franco parisi que cataliza ss
anti sistema político no esa crítica tan
dura hacia la política y lo hace de una
manera bastante
eficiente atrás de las redes sociales
claro es bastante anómala situación
porque él ni siquiera ha estado chile
nunca en toda su campaña presidencial la
estaba dirigiendo a través de las redes
sociales desde eeuu desde alabama de que
donde reside y él ha logrado capturar yo
creo que más que ponerle atención a la
figura de franco parisi hay que tener
muy muy mucha atención a ese 10% que lo
puedes situar en un tercer o cuarto
lugar y va a ser clave en una elección o
en una segunda vuelta es algo que vamos
a hacer con ese 10% si me quedan ya
pocos minutos para finalizar el programa
darío rápidamente quiero que también
responda esta pregunta la que le hacía a
gonzalo sobre el futuro de la
constitución dependiendo de esa nueva
constitución dependiendo del candidato
que llegue y si éste puede ser un
presidente de transición que haga
verdaderamente los cambios para dar un
nuevo reinicio de chile con esa nueva
constitución
si te respondió de inmediato solamente
déjame decir que lo que señalaba josé
manuel hace un instante atrás respecto
al parecido con la política española
donde probablemente muchos lo miramos es
efectivamente como si la segunda vuelta
que se prevé puedan tres box y podemos y
su gran dejado en el camino a los
populares y al psoe órgano interesante
como como imagen lo que tú me
preguntabas y yo creo que de hecho tengo
la sensación de que la segunda campaña
de gabriel boric la segunda vuelta al
balotaje probablemente pondrá foco en
aquello y probablemente será el talismán
para poder ganar ese balotaje que es
justamente el enorme peligro el enorme
peligro que corre el proceso
constitucional con la presidencia
eventual de jose antonio kast chicas
llega a la presidencia
seguramente hará una jugada al tram y
por lo tanto pondrá todas sus cartas
para que el plebiscito de salida que
viera significarse a finales del próximo
año se ha rechazado y por lo tanto
impedir que una nueva constitución
llegue y seguramente utilizará todo el
aparato del estado para que eso suceda
ese peligro que es real está latente
porque está explicitado por el propio
candidato constante no cash
que construya la mayoría en turno
gabriel boric el look humildemente
pienso si quedan pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa quiero que hagamos
conclusiones y comienzo con josé manuel
aquí en el estudio sobre lo que puede
pasar este domingo posibles escenarios y
también si usted alcanza a decirme muy
rápidamente un rápido balance del
presidente piñera muy bien bueno el
escenario yo diría que como hemos
hablado desde el comienzo del programa
es de incertidumbre y es cierto que lo
más seguro lo más probable vista las
encuestas antes de que se prohibieran la
publicación es que pasen a estos dos
candidatos de los que hemos hablado y
boric y cas y en ese escenario de
segunda vuelta es más probable que el
pues en chile gane boric que casi sobre
todo si moría es capaz de movilizar una
mayor participación electoral lo cual
significa a su vez una mayor
participación de los sectores que
normalmente no participa que es como en
cualquier país son los jóvenes y luego
sobre el balance de piñera
piñera ha tenido un segundo mandato muy
muy complejo
ha vivido las protestas sociales no la
gestión o demasiado bien con unas
represiones que desnudaban las gerencias
autoritarias del sistema político
chileno que había heredado de la
dictadura y además le tocó enfrentar una
pandemia como a otros gobiernos
latinoamericanos y siempre como hemos
estado viendo enfrentar las pandemias no
nos rinde electoralmente hablando y por
eso son a ninguno de los gobiernos de
turno ni siquiera haciendo bien el tema
de la vacuna y siendo un país líder en
la vacunación me queda un minuto del
programa 30 segundos gonzalo sus
conclusiones
y creo que lo primero la vuelvo al
concepto la palabra incertidumbre va a
estar muy presente tanto en los
resultados como en el significado de
abril boliche en su moderación voy a
tener que abrazar a parte de lo que
fueron los 30 años de la concertación un
ejercicio que no es fácil de hacer
porque eso puede desalentar a muchos que
dieron esperanza en que se va a refundar
el país y resulta que esa concertación
lo que ha hecho es administrar y porque
él va josé antonio kast también tiene
que moderarse el ambiente que dar
señales y tirar y ver qué pasa con él y
con su relación con sebastián sitges que
era el candidato del oficialismo si lo
logra o no e ir sumando apoyos más allá
de aquellos que ya tienen dario
rápidamente a 30 segundos sus
conclusiones nada solamente que me
parece que hay una crisis lo enseñará de
hecho gonzález una crisis de confianza
de legitimidad del sistema político que
tiene quizás en la joya la corona es la
presidencia no hay poder en la
presidencia por sí mismo vamos a tener
un presidente en un mes más vamos a
definir cuáles son los dos candidatos en
segunda vuelta que competirán pero eso
sólo define parte de la ecuación lo
importante es cómo es capaz de toda esta
energía que se ha proyectado en los
últimos años volver a dotar del eje el
sistema político para que la presidencia
realmente si volver a llevar adelante
transformaciones a darío a gonzalo y
josé manuel aquí en el estudio de france
24 les agradezco por haber estado con
nosotros en el programa haber analizado
este tema para nuestra audiencia ustedes
pueden seguir dejando todos sus
comentarios y preguntas en las redes
sociales siga con nosotros sigan
france24
[Música]